[Music]
[Music]
ukraine easily the best recognizable
comedian and the most successful one and
the project was like his flagship thing
was a regular comedy show it was not
what you would call hybrid humor there
was
quite a lot of kind of a primitive humor
i would say and quite a lot of
sophisticated making fun of of politics
you would just do these really funny and
clever takedowns of ukrainian
politicians russian politicians you know
because it was in many ways a shared
cultural and political spaces
is a good show it's really funny it's
about history teacher who's sort of
thrust into the presidency because of a
video of him that goes viral this is
your ultimate like a regular person
suddenly suddenly gets all the power in
the country and his heart isn't the
right place but everything is against
him there's corruption everywhere and
he's he just wants to change the country
he almost like showed on the screen what
kind of president he would be
and then i think that was his basically
campaign manifesto
[Music]
he's basically asking to people to
submit their five main problems that
they see in ukraine you could call it
like crowdsource political program his
whole campaign was a number of videos
like that but instead of doing a
professional video which he easily could
have done he was doing this little self
eclipse it worked really well for his
image of non-traditional and
establishment guide he was
keeping his program pretty weak
and empty and it worked
[Music]
his victory speech he said i am the hope
for change not just for people in
ukraine but for all people hinting
obviously on russia i still think that
putin holds big grudge on this nobody
knows what putin thought probably in all
likelihood the leadership of russia was
thinking that he's an experienced his
news this this this is our chance it's
my hypothesis that uh he was looking at
zelinski as a very easy partner who can
be played it's uh eerie to
to watch it now to be honest
i think that there's a high chance of
ending the war
when
when
as soon as possible
i want to believe that it'll be this
year the presidency was defined by a
pretty consistent and precipitous
decline in popularity we're talking
about ratings of 30s even even down to
like 20s it was connected to several
issues there was no progress in peace
there were implications of
his company listed in the pandora papers
he was trying to accumulate more power
in the office of the president which
ukrainians despise he started uh
cracking down on opposition he was
changing tremendously and he was
becoming a strong man people saw him
slipping towards the usual way of doing
business in ukraine a lot of ukrainians
were not seeing it as a successful
presidency
what is happening in that clip is that
he is holding a press conference for
foreign media
was trying to downplay the threat but
also putting out some confusing messages
these expectations of the war
they
forced many investors to leave ukraine
and of course for president zilensky it
was unacceptable in the weeks that led
up to the crisis from the communication
point of view i don't think that he did
a very good job
[Music]
officer president
premier
at the outbreak of war
there was fear and there was a suspicion
that he may you know capitulate he will
concede he'll get scared that clip
was perceived that the captain is not
abandoning the ship from that moment
people understood he is not surrendering
and there are millions of ukrainians who
are ready to put up that fight yes yes
it definitely was a turning point if you
watch queen of zilenski talking for
example to the to the western press in
january and the script of zelinski
standing on the street of kiev you can
think that these are two different
people but if you compare the script
with zilensky of 2019 when he was
campaigning for president that's the
same person the in terms of in terms of
style in terms of how you know sincere
and open he is
it's like we made full circle we came
back to the 2019 zeliensky which is the
guy people voted for
[Music]
his speech to the european parliament it
was really striking as it was translated
for the members of the european
parliament you hear the translator
fighting back tears as he's
translating zelinski's words i've never
heard that happen
just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all like cities of our country are
now blocked the moment was so emotional
and raw i think it really helped to
change a lot of minds in europe they
have to understand that for ukraine it's
the battle for existence his message is
also if we stop putting at the ukrainian
border everybody will be safer his
appeals to europe have been very much
impactful in in really making it morally
and politically impossible for them to
to stay on the sidelines and not support
ukraine today his his background as
somebody who's working with the audience
his whole life is coming come in handy
definitely knows how to command the
audience how to grasp their attention
how to put on a show so to say he
probably wasn't the best president in
peace times but he was very good in the
beginning of the work creating the hope
uniting the nation
and
giving an impetus for resistance he is
not the president anymore he's the
leader of the nation i know because i
ask people in ukraine they find it
convincing to stay in in the capital in
kiev that's uh that's really inspiring
for a lot of people in the country to
see i think it shouldn't be forgotten
that
uh
there are thousands of regular
ukrainians who are demonstrating even
bigger bravery every day unarmed
civilians trying to stop tanks with
their bare hands this
spirit of regular ukrainians is what's
inspiring velensky too he's proving
worthy of the of the nations
[Music]
you